welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka Zac's spoiler
and this video were breaking down some
big new details on the Justice of The
Ecstatic at with the film's release
confirmed for 2021 we are now slowly
starting to learn more and more about
what the plans are as well as what was
left on the cutting-room floor of the
original version throughout this video
we'll be going over what the dark side
actor Ray Porter had to say about his
betrayal what we can expect to see in
the reshoots and a statement by AT&T
defending the film's release there will
be heavy spoilers here so if you want a
couple of surprises left for the final
film then I highly recommend that you
turn off now if you still hear them may
she subscribe to the channel for updates
on the movie every time they come out
and please drop a thumbs up if you're as
excited as we are without the way thank
you for clicking this let's get into our
breakdown of the snedecker updates ok so
firstly we have to talk about the
reshoots whilst it was initially thought
that the additional work would just be
some dialogue scenes heroic Hollywood
have just dropped a report that says
Harry lennix will be doing his Martian
Manhunter scenes for the release heroic
Hollywood actually release the leaked
that the Snyder cut was going to be
getting dropped on HBO max a couple of
days before the announcement so we can
definitely add some weight to this
report we do know that Snyder did
conceptualize the scene starring Lennox
in which he was revealed as the
shape-shifting alien but that this was
never actually filmed as it was
scheduled for a date after Snyder left
the project Lennox has remained rather
coy over the matter on Twitter simply
stating that he would like to shoot it
but in order to complete Snyder's true
vision for the film this scene would
indeed need to be in place so though we
don't know for definite I personally
think it's quite likely earlier in the
year Snyder ran a fan competition on his
Viera that gave away access to watch
this scene being filmed and whilst this
prop was initially thought of as just a
little tease by the director with all
that we know it now seems more likely
this comes in the wake of rumors that
Warner Brothers are spending 30 million
dollars on completing the project and a
definitely thing that we will actually
see the scene go ahead where this will
leave the DC EU and if Lennox will get
used in future projects
means to be seen but knowing that
martian manhunter was originally meant
to be in the film and that we could have
him back definitely feels out of this
world
sorry that was the best Mars pun I could
think of on the spot where does Martian
Manhunter drink Mars bars like that that
wasn't actually that bad that one I'll
give myself that anyway it's definitely
exciting and they'll attend to say take
all rumors like this with a pinch of
salt I can actually see this one coming
to fruition as for Darkseid before the
Snyder cut was announced we did know
that the big bad of the DC EU was
originally supposed to be in the film
thanks to images from Zack Snyder's
veero account we got a look at how the
invasion of Earth was originally meant
to be in Snyder's vision it was going to
be Darkseid that was leading the charge
and after he and Steppenwolf suffered a
defeat at the hands of the earth heroes
they returned to apocalypse Steppenwolf
was cast out and he was going to try and
win favor with his nephew by conquering
earth and handing it over to him as we
know this failed but during the original
version of the film
Steppenwolf was going to be beheaded as
he retreated into a boom tube and on the
other side it would roll out directly to
where Darkseid was and he would stop it
with his boot apparently the league and
Darkseid got a look at one another and
Wonder Woman even went on to try and dig
up all that she could on the character
while stripe or I wouldn't be physically
playing the character and this would
likely be handled with CGI as similar to
Steppenwolf he was going to be voicing
him we actually have a hint of how it
was going to sound but before doing that
Porter said the following when
discussing the role I went through a few
vocal gymnastics trying to figure out
the voice
I will admit I didn't know the character
incredibly well right up to the point of
being cast it was never something I was
incredibly aware of so I didn't know all
of the cannon fortunately I happened to
be on set with people like Zack and
Chris Terrio I don't think I've ever met
anyone who understands all of the weird
things in the Canon better than those
people so there was always that steady
information as for the voice itself this
was teased at comic-con
yeah and then it was donated to the
release the Schneider Cup movement with
added effects and signed off is the way
that a character would sound he is a
clip if you haven't seen it
project comic-con mm-hmm sorry
release the Snyder Cut project comic-con
mm-hmm sorry release the Snyder cut in
addition to this film junkie have just
in an interview with Ray which I
definitely recommend you check out and
they kind of went over his life as well
as his voice in general by the sounds of
it the styling Darkseid's voice very
similar to Steppenwolf's by that I mean
that it sounds like a normal person
rather than being completely effected
and distorted and this makes sense as
they come from the same family
poured ahead stated that it took a while
for him to find the correct voice to do
the job properly but that he has finally
settled on something that he and the
production team happy with I'm still a
bit unsure as when I hear dioxide in my
head I hear a really really deep and
menacing voice but I suppose it does
seem more in line with Steppenwolf and
the other more grandiose DC characters
that we've seen on the big screen ares
and of course in chantry's though
extremely powerful also had quite
natural sounding voices so I do think
that this is what they're heading
towards to keep the universe in line we
will of course hear what the voice
sounds like when the cut is released but
in the meantime this should give you
more of an idea of what Darkseid will
sound like now before we get into the
rest of the video I just wanna let you
know we're giving away a free copy of
the marvel face repotting box set to one
random subscriber all you have to do to
be on the chance of winning is like the
video subscribe to the channel and leave
your thoughts on the updates in the
comment section below
the winner is going to be chosen at
random on the 15th of June and the
settle be shipped out from the interval
gets the price it's the best of luck to
everyone who takes part and finally we
have a statement from AT&T and HBO max
in regards to the movie's release though
fans everywhere were over the moon at
the announcement there was still some
voices of dissent saying that the
project set a dangerous precedent oh no
a movie is getting released on a
streaming service what a dangerous thing
definitely definitely the
thing that could happen this year and
the argument is that if toxic fandoms
start demanding things and bullying
people on the internet then it will just
never totally escalate I disagree with
this pretty heavily as it took years and
years to even get the ball rolling on
the project and thus tighter cut was
basically caused by an exceptional set
of circumstances such as the death of
Zach's daughter another director
stepping in Mission Impossible mustache
syndrome a pandemic and just so many
aspects that made the perfect storm for
its release anyway Tony Goncalves which
I've definitely pronounced wrong has
stepped up to the plate and said that it
isn't really a bad thing and it's good
that they listen to the fans from time
to time when asked if it was a dangerous
dangerous oh my god think of the
children
dangerous dangerous precedent he said
definitely not a precedent and you're
right there's different types of fandoms
there's the Phantom you just described
and those are the fandoms my reference
of the fandoms is the fact that we're in
a space where consumers are loud
consumers guide and we absolutely have
to listen as an industry I had a boss
that once said industry and consumers
aren't always aligned but consumers do
tend to win it's a fine balance I think
when it comes to video when it comes to
entertainment when it comes to content
consumers have never had more choice and
they've never had more of a voice but
that doesn't mean that we will go and
invest our dollars in every single
fandom that exists but I think the
reference of the Snyder cut and the
friends fandom is the fact that
consumers are speaking and we have to
listen it doesn't mean that we're gonna
go and redo every movie ever made but I
think that we definitely have to have
our ear to the ground and I think we do
I just go back and look at the buzz at
the Harry Potter Library Boris yesterday
it was a wonderful surprise and delight
it's because consumers are passionate
about these franchises hey thanks for
dropping by the show Tony much
appreciated especially with her being a
pandemic
I think thanks for stopping by I
completely agree with you and I think
that DC had kind of hit a point where
they didn't really know what direction
to go in there had been some really
successful films in the franchise such
as Wonder Woman and
c'mon but they also had ones like gee
oka that were completely separate and
did just as well the new Batman movie is
rumored to not be connected to the DCU
and thus everything is kind of up in the
air in terms of what they're doing so I
think they listen to the fans realize
that maybe they just needed to take a
step back and see that they already had
something that was worth putting out
there that would not only win people
background but also give them potential
avenues in which they could go in the
future it's the same with this channel
and though I'm not as big as Warner
Brothers probably because I'm bloody
bigger I tell you in that right yeah
that's right I do pay attention to
comments and criticisms as they can help
you out
I'm still pretty set on what videos and
topics I cover but you're stupid if you
don't realize that you're not perfect
and that you can go in a certain
direction with something I think that's
what DC have done to be honest and they
spent so long just chasing Marvel that
it really heard their movies one thing
you know it's about companies and people
that tend to chase after a certain
audience is that they often don't get it
because they become an imitation and in
doing so they also a lien ate their core
audience too so not only did they not
gain any new fans they also lose the
ones that they had I think this
definitely happened in the case of
Justice League it's actually refreshing
to see a company admit that they were
wrong and do their best to try and
correct it everything about the Snyder
car just makes sense from a business
perspective and a creative one so whilst
I don't think that Hollywood will be
doing this all the time I do think that
we will be getting a 'cut but that's for
another video
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the updates and what you
hope to see in the film comment below
and let me know and if you enjoy this
video then please give it a thumbs up
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the new Batman info as well as that's
gonna be linked at the end you want to
support the channel from as little as 99
cents a month and please click the join
button below
we massively appreciate you and as a
thank you you get access to content
early
you're gonna come chat to us after the
show in the follow us that heavy
spoilers or click the discord link in
the description below those are the best
ways to keep added a with the channel so
hopefully we see over there very soon
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thank you for taking the time to watch
this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]